first thought is I don't really know
what to do with this with regulatory
identities that I have access to it's
not a quadratic but I can abuse down to
use a tease or something squared so I'm
going to introduce this guy now by the
way please look at your piece of paper
if you did not introduce T and then you
started talking about T that's a problem
don't fix it right now you have to
introduce something if you're going to
use it now that I haven't used it I'm
just going to go back into around all of
the pizza paper that I've read three
hours ago to remember what the T results
are for sine and cosine hopefully if I
know is going off
I can play 2t on one plus P squared even
one month is where one plus P squared
plus one okay
I've translated from trig into algebra
so now I just enter of dollars typically
I'm going to multiply through as you see
a few times today already now to become
two T this is going to become 1 minus T
squared this becomes just as a minor
note and we saw this in the example this
morning I'm going to encourage you when
you transition from this line to this
line the one I've just written I'm going
to encourage you to put brackets even
where they are redundant to tell and
tell me what common error are those
brackets going to help me avoid when
there's negatives right so for instance
suppose this question was - codex
right I'm going to introduce this or
multiply through now if I write minus 1
minus T squared
I'm clipping trouble on time because I
haven't carried that double negative so
you have to watch out for that in this
case it doesn't make a difference but I
want to get into the right habits which
doesn't matter so it does have no
problems okay
who has this exact line by the way yes
so type this great and you can see but
what if this ends up it's just sort of
covered out in the wash
two teeth on the left hand side
you end up with a line that could be it
sorry
of course wishes to take just wait until
we're already have a solution to say but
I introduced to the original question
has nothing to do with it so therefore
it's my obligation to go back to what
the question is really about which is X
certain I undo the substitution in this
puzzle now 10 or something equals 1 this
is an exact value in fact I even enjoyed
pretty well what's the angle 25 right so
x2 equals 45 degrees is that the only
solution no what's the other one
now interestingly I'm actually not going
to write or what 225 is why do you
remember when I showed you
we're doing trigonometric graphs mainly
and I say at all or geometric equations
which are super stop if I can see
something like this something like this
strength and I said ok X unless you say
the domain of X between mastery degrees
between north and 360 he remembers right
but I said hey wait watch out you're not
just solving in terms of X anymore
this is actually a trigonometric
function in terms of 2 X so therefore
that has an effect on this do you
remember this is actually going to be
when I think about what 2 X is really
between you have to multiply everything
by C so that really becomes 720 okay so
rather than just saying 3150 I done in
this term and I have more solutions
31:51 compare 3 393 MCTV layoffs and 510
I think okay so look those 395 chance
they're in this domain so they've got to
be included to you right now take that
ideas bring it over this here there's no
2x or to clean or anything like that
what happened to you right there okay
so if X is between 936 T then X on two
is between 1 and 1 not in 180 now when
you think of what the next solution is
going to be it's gonna be 225 is that in
the domain and so no so you can write if
you want or 225 and then execute it but
if I've written up here and recognized
you know what this is a very close to me
this is the only solution that you're
fine okay I don't want to continue I
want X so I will multiply through and I
have a solution but I suggest that
support whenever you solve an equation
you can always check let's see what
happens is 90 varies really a solution
slider by degrees co.design breeze
Johnny check out it does what's good it
just like one teeny little from a goon
now I've posed this question to you and
I know some even working away so maybe
you was quite focusing in here my
question to you was if you didn't have T
results if you didn't know how to do all
this what could you do to approach this
question now you actually all have all
the knowledge you need to answer that
question without key results
I just haven't given you really any
clues to keep you in that direction sinx
do you know what sine x looks like do
you have a picture in your head what
side x looks like start in the origin
and then what do goes up like that so
you know what sine x looks like do you
know what collects looks like it starts
from 1 and from there and it dips and it
comes back up now you don't have codecs
do you you have code x plus 1 so you
take that shape right and you're going
to move it upwards okay help me out what
does this look like that's right
you told me and you should have the
story too you told me son start the
article and it doesn't weigh anything
and there's your graph yes
now Chordettes you know what that looks
like if you superimpose that but I
actually want context plus 1 that means
it's its range is no longer negative 1
to 1 it's going to be 0 to 2 yes
what's it going to look like codex
starts up in from context plus one
another and then it's going to dip down
how far is it going to dip what's the
bottom spot it's going to get to linger
it usually gets to negative one but I've
goofed it up so it's going to go there
is or not and then it's going to come
back up something like that what do you
think so if this is silence and this is
cos x plus one what does it mean to
solve this by visually would that mean
it means where do they intersect now you
totally want to listen here it is there
is it is this guy here right I'm a
little off but you get the idea right
that's where the turning point is
suicide x equals 90 in the solution and
we test it out but when we see a
solution
why are we in the same solution where is
the solution underneath 180 degrees they
clearly intercept that's kinda why I
chose this particular graph because you
can see it felt like some reader now you
like mommy took this morning okay